welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of one
division episode one
launching the mcu's next face with a
quirky sitcom that's actually hiding a
horrifying secret
spoiler warning before we continue
because even though these first few
episodes don't reveal much about what's
really going on inside wanda's pocket
reality
i am seeing dozens of potential clues
hiding in plain sight
we started to answer some of these big
questions in inside marvel earlier but
now let's break down episode one shot by
shot for everything we missed episode
two's breakdown's coming out tomorrow
also be sure to check out our new latest
obsession shirt and unusual couple it's
so cool
with the secret augmented reality easter
eggs it's gonna sell out fast so get it
at newrockstarsmerch.com and you can
write in a custom shout out that we will
feature in inside marvel and epic hero
shop released a companion shirt with
wanda
and its own ar secrets keep this unusual
couple together
and epic hero shop is giving away 10
playstation 5s folks
just subscribe to their youtube channel
epic hero labs fill out the form at epic
hero shop
giveaway they are announcing a new
winner every 10 000 subscribers there's
a bunch of ways to get more giveaway
entries at epiccaroshop.com giveaway
okay this episode opens with something
we have missed these past 18 months the
marvel studios fanfare it has been
updated with shots from endgame and
infinity war cap catchy mjolnir tony
snap black panthers shockwave bucky and
rockets team up doctor strange's wizard
duel
and notice how every avenger turns black
and white until the whole freaking thing
turns monochrome
letterbox aspect ratio and the audio
condenses
as if coming from an old tv speaker
[Music]
reflecting this whole reality shifting
to that of an old sitcom
inside wanda's illusion reality the
opening credits are modeled on the theme
of the dick van dyke show
the dick van dyke show
the real estate sign has a 732 area code
which is for new jersey make me wonder
if this pocket reality is actually
located somewhere close to camp lehigh
oh but before we continue big thanks to
raid shadow legends for sponsoring this
video
raid is a popular game that you can play
on your mobile device or your
desktop it's got 10 challenging dungeons
each with a
super tough boss that you've got to get
creative to beat there are 13
unique factions of champions like
dwarves orcs or the
undead raid has an incredible 460
champions
each totally unique with their own
design skills and strengths
raid is super active with over 200 000
clans
fighting and competing right now with
over 25 million players the raid
community is huge and only getting
bigger
my favorite part of this game is
equipping the champions figuring out the
right combination of armor and weapons
to help my barbarians and dark elves be
all they can be last month raid released
their biggest ever update with the
release of the doom
tower an entirely new part of the game
with 120 floors
a bunch of secret challenge rooms and 12
seriously badass bosses to take on
and now is a great time to start playing
raid is giving away a bunch of free
goodies plus a special champion
bulwark to help get you started in the
tower he's awesome in clan boss and he's
also gonna be a huge help in the doom
tower
if you want a huge head start in raid
hit the link in the description new
players get the free
boy champion bulwark 50 gems an xp
booster
energy refills and an ancient shard when
you join
all this treasure will be waiting for
you right here you can find me in game
under the name
new rock 2020 and if you're quick enough
you can even
join my clan and it's that easy click
the link in the description
and i will see you in the game this home
set is based on the home set of the dick
van dyke show
dick van dyke himself actually consulted
on the slapstick humor that wanda and
vision are showing
vision phase shifts through the door but
leaves wanda behind but inside you can
see she learns from this and does a
little spell to phase shift with him
through that chair notice the opening
lines of this show and the opening words
of marvel's phase four
my wife are the flying sources my
husband and his indestructible head
a little wordplay but a visceral nod to
the precise way
vision died when thanos caved in his
forehead to
pry out the mind stone it also makes you
wonder if wanda's flying saucers could
add up to anything given the
organization monitoring them
sword is known to be marvel's shield
offshoot for extraterrestrial threats
they are confused by this mystery date
on their calendar we can get a lot from
this calendar actually it's the month of
august and it starts on a tuesday there
are only
so many years in history where that has
been the case 2023
when in the mcu timeline wanda still
technically would have been dusted the
endgame events were thought to have
occurred in october
1950 but notice that art all this little
girl wants is a color television
color tv was not invented until 1953 and
was not a widely available consumer good
until like the 60s
also the year on the wine bottle later
is 1953 so i am guessing this is
august 1961 which is also the year that
the dick van dyke show premiered
also that calendar art shows some
butterflies on the wall
maybe that's where wanda will get her
inspiration for her baby crib
butterflies for her future nursery
vision's west view newspaper reads the
headline little baby jen's first word
tickles mother sue
it's a kind of lifestyle non-story that
should not be front page news
also note the calendar was released by
west view appliances
so it seems like everything in this town
is all part of the same truman showy
fictitiousness
and we meet agnes a name we suspect
could be derived from
agatha harkness the witch companion to
wanda who secretly serves mephisto
catherine han's delivery is so specific
it's hard not to see every single one of
her lines and gestures as containing
some hidden double meaning
wanda charm charmed as in
charmed under a witch's spell perhaps
and then there's her husband ralph that
she keeps bringing up the only way ralph
would remember our anniversary as if
there was a beer named june
2nd not that ralph ever wants to eat
anything other than baked beans
are you sure you don't want an audience
volunteer named my husband ralph
no one asked about your husband ralph
agnes so i assume he is either a corpse
or never existed or
her pet named for mephisto or somehow
all three and then she leaves with
this is gonna be a gap gas as in
gaslighting
yeah yeah roll your eyes but i'm telling
you one of these is gonna mean something
at work vision and norm are listening to
the coasters 1958 hit yakity yak with
lyrics about a kid being yelled at to do
household chores if you think about it
it's actually similar to the
generational conflict vision and wanda
will find themselves in having to cook
dinner for his much older boss and his
wife which are very much authoritarian
parental figures to them and the office
background is a trophy
i assume this could be the bowling
trophy that the guys later say arthur
actually bought at a yard sale
you know those bowling trophies arthur
is always polishing i bought them all at
a yard sale in hackensack
mr hart has fired poor jones whose wife
dottie whom we meet in episode two could
not impress the boss apparently
the wife thought five courses would be
sufficient actually jones getting fired
and vision getting promoted might
explain some of dottie's hostility to
wanda in episode two
or you know it could just be wanda is
trapping all these poor souls in her
dream bubble and that's what she's
pissed the magazine agnes and wanda reed
is
glamorous a spin on glamour magazine
this also could be the inspiration for
her magic act stage name glamour
now these episodes feature amazing
commercial breaks that are filled with
mcu easter eggs the toastmate 2000 from
stark industries stark being howard
stark who was into all of his consumer
marvels
but listening closely when the toaster
warms up
yeah that toaster is making the stark
repulsor warm-up sound effect
now the toaster light turns red giving
us our first little splash of
technicolor on this series
which will return every time really we
start to question the reality
yeah notice how that beeping speeds up
kind of like how the ticking does for
the striker watch in episode 2.
[Music]
we could see this as time speeding up
for wanda as she is moving forward
through the decades there's also
obviously something to the slogan forget
the past this is your future it's very
sinister right it also kind of
evokes that idea of wanda being
gaslighted forget about where you came
from
just focus on what you got to do now
make babies vision explains the
horny confusion by referencing wanda's
sakovian background
this is the traditional sokovian
greeting of hospitality trailer footage
tells us this series will
revisit wanda's origin with the mind
stone in that hydra lab in sokovia and
maybe the death of her brother pietro in
age of ultron agnes shows up with a full
meal ready to cook
so this menu can be done in a snack
seriously snap
you know that i am ready to go with a
theory that one of these endgame snaps
warped reality in a way to activate
mutant genes
in the way that infinity stone radiation
activated wanda's mutant genes
just saying mark this line we're coming
back to it wanda accidentally burns the
chicken but then she rewinds too far
back making it eggs which is a bit weird
because one chicken should just come
from one egg but i am interested in how
this parallels wanda's final moments
with vision think about it she used her
sorcery to
cook him to a crisp but then that
cooking got rewound
so that he could be served up for
another purpose kind of like these eggs
are now during all the goofing around
agnes shows up again with a pineapple
you didn't answer the back door for your
upside down cake
oh hi hmm well first off fruit seems to
be an important motif to the show
trailer footage shows wanda with orange
slices later vision catching a papaya
and then there's that little wave
agnes does up vision's body the first
time agnes tries to meet him wanda slams
the door in her face as if she's trying
to protect vision from her and that wave
is similar to the one wanda does in
episode 2 to scan vision's body this
could be kind of a witch spell to appear
inside this person dinner is served it's
actually the breakfast wanda promised at
the top of the episode but with
wine maison du mapree which we pointed
out in the trailer breakdown translates
to house of misery really house of
contempt
it might be a nod to the scarlet witch
house of m comics that we suspect this
is all partially based on where wanda
reframes reality so that mutants do and
do not exist some of those mutants
including her children
actually when jimmy kimmel asked
elizabeth olsen about this she played
dumb and credited the art department
guys
our prop guy russell would be very a
very clever man
if he put that in jimmy also asked her
about the thai
theory that i came up with that that
thai design could reflect two people
trapped inside as other people are
peering in on them
like juan invention could be in this
reality now as they said mrs hart hits
them with a ton of questions at once
where did you two move from
what brought you here how long have you
been married and why don't you have
children yet
children again as we see in episode 2
this town is obsessed with the children
you could argue that all of west view is
really designed to trick wanda into
manifesting children i'll also note that
mrs hart bombards wanda with questions
before she can answer them all the same
way
agnes did when they first met so what's
your name where are you from
and most importantly how's your bridge
game hon arthur chokes and vision has to
reveal his powers to save him
let the hearts just leave as if nothing
happened also i find it suspect that
arthur does not appear at all in episode
2 alongside mrs hart she actually sits
at the table with
agnes it's almost as if arthur has been
removed from this cast
in the final scene wanda blips some
rings on their fingers i love that shaky
jump cut it's very bewitched and then
credits roll but these are all fake
names this is all being observed from a
sword
research station monitor room on another
nearby screen
are two graphs one red one green maybe
corresponding to wandas
and visions heart rates or their levels
of consciousness but again
vision is dead so maybe this is wanda's
consciousness and the consciousness of
another
undetermined presence now there are
definitely some interesting visuals in
the credit sequence as we soar through
the red blue green pixels of a tv screen
the red ones reshape into new forms
arose a house the town finally two
interlocked rings
as if to say everything we're seeing on
this is just manifested td illusions
my breakdown of all the details you
missed in episode 2 will come out next
on the channel
even more clues up and let's figure out
what westview is and who is doing this
to wanda we go into a lot of those
theories and inside marvel be sure to
check out that follow me at ea boss
following your rockstar subscribe to
rockstars here on youtube thank you for
watching and now you can stop watching
stop it stop it
stop it stop it stop it stop it stop it
[Music]
my stomach